boy come here man come here come here
just bring it you got this you got a
rabbit in the building just bring your
ass in here man come on
what's this you want this yes Sour Patch
Sour Patch Kids for the children you
bother being a dentist
rocking with this your teeth you're
gonna have like a whole bunch of silver
teeth you're gonna have teeth like
Spencer yeah
[Music]
by the way Lambo when Spencer gets here
he's gonna hit you up so you could go
he's gonna be here in like five go see
uh Max and Lambo okay Daddy got to
finish go
all right nice uh nice appearance by a
little man nice appearance yeah he could
have him
um
but it's crazy because like obviously
you've been taking your time at this
project your first album on Warner
you've been throwing out singles right
last couple of years
um
I know that we're getting this snuck in
like right before the Grammy
considerations are cut off for the year
I'm sure yeah it was on purpose
hey champ eat your candy and chill out
I don't care about the Grammy man give
me dad of the Year man it's hard job
being a rapper and being a dad man yeah
nah but uh yeah we did that on purpose
because I mean of course you know once
you get considered
rabbit go outside you can hang out in
there and go outside on TV you tripping
that's not you want to throw something
on the uh the computer forms YouTube or
something on the studio computer
just won't let me be great at all man
it's all good man I'm surprised when I
did that uh that the one freestyle that
he sat still that whole time but I was
about to be disaster
right before I had to like be like hey
man you better chill dog he was like
much smaller yeah I know he now he just
got to mind his own he was like then he
was like two now he's like four and he
just well four year olds are like
they're like little men yeah he not
stopping talking he's like yo you don't
care if he gotta say something he's
saying it out loud he's not a Whisperer
at all so yeah shout out to uh first of
all what is like for you being a father
obviously you you know you have uh
you have always kind of stood on like
being a good dad which is something that
like we don't see a lot in hip-hop like
you always make sure that you you get
your kids no matter what the situation
is with the moms you know what I'm
saying like
yeah yeah you got to do what you got to
do you know what I mean and you know
shout out to their moms you know I mean
their moms you know they they all they
all good women it's all it's all smooth
you know anything you know that you uh
got that you love is gonna be
complications with it so you know it'd
be like that you know but everybody you
know really own you know got the same
general Mission you feel me